salve a tutti e per questo video di
penombra siamo al quarto episodio e con
questo sugo la pesca e pesca si direi
che abbiamo il carburante giusto per
affrontare pif i suoi amici già voglio
morire però rimasti ragazzuoli che c'è
la gente che mi rincorreva di ecco
questo non si apre lo ricordò che la
gente che mi rincorreva nel corridoio
per che spunta la madonna con si apre di
ovvero come forse superato questa
partita ancora capito che si supera e
para palco demonio
niente io non riuscirò mai a passo sta
roba forse devo andare esattamente dove
è uscito lui il problema che non so dove
uscito prima salta madonna e anche
incubi fai così schifo e vabbè ho
saltato l'ho saltato vai via via via via
papa niente sta crollando tutto ora
riman mia ragazzi orribile sto gioco
diventa sempre peggio
eravamo già in punti difficili figurati
se la gente mi segue pure cosa giusta
caverna di un ascensore possiamo uscire
ci credo tanto io piano di sopra
no ragazzi non ci credo non siano seri
se uscire sul serio vi rendete conto di
quanto siamo in basso che guarda in alto
per chilometri non vedo l'uscita ama e
rilassante potevate dirmelo prima gara
sapevo portato gli amici di prima
madonna che anzi non riuscire mai a
stare in un ascensore così i cag e ray
troppo addosso
beh però karin allegra la musica
l'importante quello potevamo mettere una
tarantella siciliana che c'eravamo
gesù non l'avevo visto non sapevo della
sua esistenza ed era meglio se non lo
sapevo meno male che ho tirato con una
ginocchiata la scrivania e tutto questo
mi sono anche fatto male ma non fa
niente ragazzi spiega mi water park tuoi
dirmi che il virus era alieno il virus
capo di questo casino loro non
incapsulato l'hanno testato sulle
persone rendendole mostri e ammazzando i
soldati scienziati mamma mi ha commesso
dare le spiegazioni io non è da nessuno
finita questa scalata incredibile
sull'ascensore mammamia pensa se dovevo
farmela a piedi almeno un posto nuovo
finalmente diverso dagli altri giorno
scusi ma allora non dovrò mai tornare
giù spero iddio quindi tutto quello che
mi sono lasciato alle spalle melo si è
lasciato alle spalle comunque il
fratello nudo di prima da qualche parte
sarà andato ai ragazzi ve lo dico posso
e bloccato sbarrato di entrambi i casi
non intenzione di passarci va benissimo
lo devi stare calmo zio apache l'uscita
a capirla exit sia aperta ad uscita
proprio le sue scola non ha speso ci
credo mi fa veramente uscire sono fuori
calmi
o atti
perché sono uscito sono aperto su un
freddo boia
c'è un freddo cane ma ci sono sono fuori
aprite aprite erano 120 esistono sono
tipo dei check point per non morire di
freddo bello strano sifone di come
funziona via ciao stato bello quindi con
gelo e muoio cosa devo fare qui l'esito
un ponte di via componente no devo
rientrare perché fa troppo freddo certo
tutto sto casino per poi rientrare
dentro è pace fried giovanna aiutami la
mia amica a mapello
hai dovuto legare i ponti
grazie a ma bella va bene allora troverò
qualcosa per collegare i ponti let's go
cani non si apre apparentemente
congelato chissenefrega ho visto dei
cani segui i cani sono dati di qua ho
visto dei cani raga opposto siamo stati
noi
però ci proviamo dove trai qualcosa
perché mi serve per girare nei ponti non
ho capito bene cosa devo salire lì sopra
devo arrivare dall'altra parte ti ho
anche rappando mia qualcosa tipo
assassin's creed immaginavo o una
capacità di apprendimento veramente
incredibile sarà riguardo alberto angela
dunque prendi questa roba qua la metti
qua poi tiri questo e poi sai qua hai
fatto mamma mia che pro gay merda
teoricamente poi non so se se io ci
salto sopra faccio parkour
marcora aspetto ci sono un po di capelli
sotto questa rumena non è che cosa ci
sto facendo qua dentro però va bene il
dubbio port col demonio gesù mi è pure
ma che male che portano ha dato tua
sorella in panne i rilievi ha detto
ancora gridare prezzo di schifo guarda
una donna cui mi son cagato 2 gasoline
addio cielo dovremo aver fatta
teoricamente ecco la top 12 ecco un'ora
e mezza la pasta cosa scherzato il ponte
uno che stiamo io che muoio
come schiacciavano
l'aveva perfetto volevo questo io lo sto
bordello per fast a roma però tanto
guarda fate entrare da quel grazie non
avrei mai pensato di dirlo ma sto
morendo di freddo quindi non mi salvate
o vi fate entrare perché non c'è vero
fuori si schiatta dentro si vive lì o la
poppa
evviva le olive permesso c'è un buco è
buono ho fatto io una voragine profonda
probabilmente la mamma degli hate erano
presenti sotto di quella nato terme
della roccia ma maria the world
qualcosa il fermo ecologicamente madonna
è brutto vermi ogm in tutto questo
lascia palermo
questo mondo android asma la mia tipa
quella che dovrebbe limon armi e ancora
qua in giro mia sta fregando o salvezza
mi scusi ma lei è uno fidato perché mi
serve del sangue perfetto era un fidato
io l'avrei portato proprio tutto di peso
l'ho capito spiega chi è che el mona che
chiude le porte li tiene la porta aperta
via atenea porta
chi è che il mappa ticket sulle porte
che se trovo quello che mi ha fatto
incazzare tier 1 che lo spacco la testa
devo passarvi qua credo cosa si dice io
la siringa uso nel mac o mamma mia che
il sistema di sicurezza incredibile
anche il mio nonno ci passava dentro
trova berta aperta vamos devo uscire
adesso posso arrivare nella vedete che
dove si trova la mia amica ce l'abbiamo
fatta ragazzi più o meno che hai visto
un po che non
no no non ci credo corri corri vado non
ci voglio magari prima ma sei stupido ma
mica un distintivo quando uno stupido
modena guarda ticinello minimo perché
sono fisico come tra l'altro giorno sono
caduto nei meandri del demonio non
sappiamo dove siamo tanto per cambiare è
però allegro almeno quello il posto
allegro e tranquilli segui da mesi
abbiamo cambiato gioco poi io così pure
le dona pure il ragazzino fate le
donazioni quando sto giocando i giochi
horror bene prego a caso poi non so se è
un saab però ricevere iscritti mentre
giochi l'horror e il problema è un
problema come si uccidono come lucido
schiaccia
e vabbè era immortale immortale
immortali mortale non si sale più non si
sa è più che non ci sono
no ragazzi io lo sto gioco non lo posso
giocare non lo posso fare
ma guarda se dovuto aggiunge commissioni
radici sono un sacco di horror non so
parlare un sacco di horror
al giorno d'oggi e noi io ho scelto
quello coi ragni va bene va bene faccio
schifo d'accordo ve perfetta ma c'era
un'altra botola di lato bello scoprirlo
un'ora dopo
porco schifo sposta i ragni non possono
essere fatti fuori ottimo beh questa è
una bella cosa da scoprire
si può aprire la porta e molto vecchi in
cattive condizioni
guardai come molti posti fatto o
l'artefatto posto praticamente entrare
nel punto di prima è esattamente questo
usalo questo serve il magnete scusate
cristo cosa sto pensando alla cosa
giusta per la ies viaggio nel passato
trig mentale al trading
successe che non ho capito cosa è
successo alla casa ho trovato
[Musica]
gokhan e aia non mi tocca ne aspetta che
un casino qua
ho trovato una chiave però c'è un cane
dietro e non è il massimo
ecco lecco via via via via gli avanti
che ci stanno a porco il demonio che ne
so quale la pa 1938 proviamo tutto nel
cervello tutto tutta la tutto qua tutto
tutto qua tutto qua ragazzi tutto qua
aveva usato l'anno di 938 incredibile
l'unica passione
ora poi allora minute per quote però non
è crollato niente l'hack è male nova bei
ragazzoni prof
ve lo chiedo per cortesia no no no no no
come si è
ma come chiuso tua madre chiusa madonna
che odio che ciò per questo gioco dietro
davanti poi l'altro non potrebbe
scappare prima che scappa quando vuole
lui
così pure il cane sarà messo prima gira
la manopola e non li posso fare fuori
che faccio muoio pato è tanto ma cosa
devo fare qua io sono andata se n'è
andato basta cosiddetti che schifo togli
lì
se ti della webcam che non si stacca
ostia che serve sta roba qua sono qua
sto girando sto girando la pasta perché
escano un sali già fatta buongiorno sono
contento di essere in uno è guerra
sempre più al mese sta diventando ma
come è possibile dove sono arrivato ma i
ragnetti bello allegro no ecco ciò che
ha scalato subito vabbè apposto dai
fatto niente
sono tornato il secondo tutto questo è
un sogno sto facendo per niente un sogno
maledizione la mia vita cos'è un uscita
prendi per il dell'età tanto siamo in un
sogno che me frega fra bello si è
l'uscita effettivamente a noi siamo
sempre dentro una caserma
c'è semplicemente mozzafiato credo che
sia la navicella spaziale in tutto qua
ma sì spacchiamo celegato
entro dentro la porta no di alternative
scendere le scale veloci
yes caraglio come la radio scatola
smentendo stai zitto che cosa sta
succedendo sto scomparso perché entrato
tentare da sta roba qua no a misano
risponde cosa però mi è crashato ragazzi
con quello qui l'episodio di penombra
continua nel prossimo sono sempre bravo
a concludere i momenti più belli bravi
sia piaciuto ma se non ti piace qui di
seguito da giustiziare se ne sono resi
schiavi e non è come sempre ci vediamo
da ragazzi
[Musica]